قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان مسيرات روسيه
استهدفت ميناء اسماعيل احد الموانئ جنوب
غربيه مقاطعه اوديسا وهو احد اكبر الموانئ
النهريه للحبوب في اوكرانيا ويقع على نهر
الدانوب على الحدود مع رومانيا
للمتابعه معنا من اوديسا مراسل الجزيره
عامر اللافي ومن دنيتك مراسل الجزيره نور
الدين قد غير اهلا وسهلا بكما وابدا بك
عامل استطلاعنا على اخر التطورات في ضوء
هذا القصف على الميناء الالهام بالذات
لتصدير الحبوب
نعم عثمان مازال مستوى التهديد قائما وفقا
للجيش الاوكراني على اعتبار ان الجيش
الاوكراني يتحدث عن رصده لعده سفن وغواصه
يحملون حتى الان كما قال الجيش نحو اثنا
عشر صاروخا من نوع كليبر وهي جاهزه
للاطلاق وبالتالي اذا اوديسا ما زالت
معرضه للخطر وتحذر الناس وتحذر المواقع
هنا في اوديسا من احتمال قصفها مجددا بعد
القصف المهم الذي تحدثت عنه وهو استهداف
ميناء زميل في جنوب غرب هذه المدينه ما
جرى وفقا لقياده العمليات في المنطقه
الجنوبيه عثمان هو ان عده طائرات من نوع
شاهد ايرانيه الصنع انطلقت فجره هذا اليوم
من بحر ازوف عبر البحر الاسود نحو هذا
الميناء المطل على نهر الدانوب الذي يصب
في البحر الاسود قال قياده عمليات الجنوب
بان
المضادات الارضيه الدفاع الجوي اشتبك مع
هذه الاسراب من الطائرات نحو ثلاث ساعات
وتمكن خلال هذه المواجهه من اسقاط 11
مسيره من نوع شاهد لكن عدد من هذه
المسيرات تمكنت من الوصول الى اهدافها
قصفت وضربت مواقع داخل هذا الميناء وتضرر
بشكل كبير المبنى الاداري للميناء وتضررت
بطبيعه الحال الهدف الرئيسي صوامع الحبوب
ومنشات ايضا داخل هذا المبنى وفقا لوزير
البنيه التحتيه الاوكراني قال بان اربعين
الفا طنا من الحبوب تدمرت خلال هذا القصف
الذي استهدف هذا الميناء ميناء اسماعيل
الذي اصبح من الموانئ المهمه جدا في
الفتره الاخيره بعد ان توقف العمل في
الموانئ على البحر الاسود المواني الكبيره
اكبر موانع في اوكرانيا موانئ اوديسا
وبالتالي اوكرانيا فعلت هذه الموانئ
موانئها على نهر الدانوب وبدات تستخدمها
لتصدير الحبوب الى مختلف العالم وتحديدا
ميناء هنري الذي استهدف قبل تقريبا ميناء
رينيه عفوا الذي استهدف قبل حوالي عده
ايام واليوم يستهدف هذا الميناء ميناء
اسماعيل وبالتالي واضح ان اوكرانيا تحاصر
بشكل كبير في موضوع تصدير الحبوب اليوم
المتحدث باسم القياده العسكريه هنا في
مدينه اوديسا تحدث عن الوضع وصف ما جرى
بانه تكتيك روسي لتدمير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
وصف اوكرانيا بانها دوله ارهابيه وقال
بانها لن تنجح في تحقيق مخططاتها فلنستمع
لما قال
يستمر العدو بتكتيكاته لتدمير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه هذا ما يستهدفه العدو من هجومه
على منشاه الموانئ وهذا ما استهدفه العدو
في جنوب اوديسا حيث نفذت غاره بالطائرات
المسيره وللاسف هناك اصابه لموقع وتضررت
الصوامع جميع فرق الطوارئ في الموقع روسيا
دوله ارهابيه ولن نمكنها من تنفيذ خطتها
نور الدين هل كان هناك اي تصريح روسي عن
عن هذا القصف
عثمان بكل تاكيد الحديث هنا يقتصر عما
تقوم به القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه الجانب
الروسي لذا الحديث هنا على المستوى
العسكري ينطوي على مساحات متعدده من
المواجهات ومنطقه اوديسا والبحر الاسود
احدى نقاط هذه المواجهه ما يتم نقله هنا
ومتى نقلته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه والجيش
الروسي حينما يتم الحديث عن محاوله
استهداف جديده كانت ستطال احدى السفن
الحربيه الروسيه في البحر الاسود كذلك
هناك قبل يوم كذلك كان هناك محاوله
استهداف عبر المسيرات المائيه لذلك الحديث
هنا في روسيا عن اي استهداف لمنطقه اوديسا
واطراف هناك هناك منطقين اساسيين هناك
المنطق العسكري الذي يتحدث به الروس
والذين والذي يقولون فيه بان اي استهداف
لتلك الاماكن اولا باعتبارها انها مكان
مستودع مهم لعدد من الاسلحه التي
تعمل ضد روسيا وخاصه ضد شبه جزيره القرم
وضد مصالح روسيا على مستوى البحر الاسود
سواء على مستوى صواريخ او على مستوى او
على مستوى المسيرات لذلك الحديث من روسيا
الان هو ان الاستهدافات في اوديسان تستهدف
مواقع الذخيره مواقع الدعم الاستراتيجي
للقوات الاوكرانيه لذلك الان روسيا تركز
على هذا المجال من الجانب العسكري وكذلك
هناك جانب تقني قد يرتبط بمن له السيطره
وفرض السيطره داخل البحر الاسود لذلك الان
روسيا تتحدث بهذا المنطق العسكري على انها
صاحبه اليد الطولى بهذا المجال وان اي
تحرك ربما يجب ان يمر عبر البوابه الروسيه
وليس عبر اي بوابات اخرى اذا هكذا تتحدث
روسيا في منطلق في في مساله البحر الاسود
وما يحدث هناك لكن بكل تاكيد عثمان
المواجهه ليست مفتوحه فقط على هذا المجال
هناك مواجهات مفتوحه في الجانب الجنوب من
دنيات هناك تحرك للقوات الاوكرانيه هناك
انزال لعديد من القوات تتحدث وزاره الدفاع
ومعلومات عسكريه على انه ما يقارب من
ثمانيه الاف عسكري اوكراني ربما يجتمعون
الان وتم انزالهم في منطقه باتجاه
روبوتينيو هاته المنطقه التي تحاول قوه
اوكرانيا جاهزه السيطره عليها لكن بكل
تاكيد الحديث هنا من موسكو من روسيا من
الجيش الروسي على ان قوات الصد الدفاعي
الروسيه سواء المدفعيه قوات الطيران كذلك
تحاول صد هذا الهجوم وهو ما عبرت عنه
وزاره الدفاع والمتحدث لوزاره الدفاع فيما
سنستمع اليه الان
كيف
خلال الليل حاول نظام كييف مهاجمه سفينه
تابعه للبحريه الروسيه كانت ترافق النقل
البحري المدني في الجزء الجنوبي الغربي من
البحر الاسود بقارب المسير وقد اكتشف
القارب الاوكراني ودمر بالوقت المناسب
واعترضت انظمه الدفاع الجوي 12 صاروخا من
طراز هايمرس ودمر الثماني 28 مسيره
اوكرانيه في مناطق مختلفه خلال الساعات
الاربع والعشرين الماضيه
شكرا جزيلا اذا بعمر لافي من اوديسا ونور
الدين غير من دمياطسك